مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشاط الرابع من
الرياض
تتخللها قمه خليجيه وعربيه
الدول الخليج يعقدون اجتماعا تحضيريا
للقمه الخليجيه الصينيه
لفائضا متوقع 9 مليارات ريال مجلس الوزراء
السعوديه قيد جلسه لاقرار ميزانيات العام
الجديد
رابعه
بعد تخاطيه تيران اسبانيا احتفالات عربيه
ومغربيه بتاكل اسود الاطلس الى ربع
النهائي
بدعوه من العاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز يبدا الرئيس الصيني جيم بنج
اليوم زياره الرسميه الى السعوديه تستمر
ثلاثه ايام
ستعقد خلال قمه سعوديه صينيه واخرى خليجيه
صينيه وثالثه عربيه صينيه وسيعقد العاهل
السعودي والرئيس الصيني محادثات رسميه
تتناول العلاقات الثنائيه والشراكه
الاستراتيجيه التي تجمع البلد
[موسيقى]
وقد كده السفير الصيني لدى السعوديه
على استعداد لبدل جهود المشتركه مع الرياض
لمواصله تعميق علاقات شراكه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله وفقاء صحيفه الشرق الاوسط واشار
السفير في ذات الصدد الى ان العالم سيشهد
اول قمم تعقد بين الصين والدول العربيه
وبين الصين ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي على
مستوى القدم
الخارجيه والعربيه استعدادا لعقد قمم
الرياض الخارجيه الصينيه للتعاون والتنميه
وقمه الرياضه العربيه الصينيه للتعاون
والتنميه وذلك اثناء زياره الرئيس الصيني
جيمنج التي تبدا اليوم وتستمر ثلاثه ايام
سيتم خلالها مناقشه سهول تعزيز العلاقات
المشتركه بين الدول المشاركه في كافه
المجالات وبحث افاق التعاون الاقتصادي
والتنموي
التوجه الان الى المركز الاعلامي لقمم
الرياض حيث يتواجد هناك زملايه في الاحمري
مرحبا نايف تفضل اليك
شكرا خالد مساء الخير لك ولكل مشاهدي
العربيه اهلا بكم الى هذه التغطيه الخاصه
التي تواكب فيها العربيه قمم الرياض هذه
الزياره المرتقبه المرتقبه طبعا للرئيس
الصيني سجن بنج الى العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض التي سيعقد فيها مع السعوديه مع
الخليج مع ايضا القاده العرب ثلاث قمم
تاتي في وقت هام دقيق حساس ايضا كما يصفه
بعض المراقبين في دلالاته الدوليه
الاقليميه والسياسيه والاقتصاديه ايضا
كذلك الكثير من الملفات ستكون حظيره في
هذه القمم كما تابعنا قبل قليل شوارع
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض تزينت بالاعلام
السعوديه الصينيه وكذلك اعلام الدول
الخليجيه العربيه التي سترك في هذه القمم
الرياض ترتقب وصول الرئيس الصيني اليها في
هذه الزياره الرسميه التي اتت بدعوه من
العاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان بن العزيز
الى الرئيس همم الصيني والتي كما ذكرنا
سيعقد فيها همم القمم الثلاثه السعوديه
الصينيه والصينيه الخليجيه وكذلك الصينيه
همم العربيه العديد من الاسئله ربما حول
هذه القمه في توقيتها في دلالاتها نحاول
ان نناقش اكثر في هذه القمم الذي يمكن ان
تحمله كذلك من ملفات هنا مع ضيف الدكتور
عبد العزيز بن صقر الباحث السياسي اهلا بك
دكتور عبد العزيز بدايه ما الذي يجعل
الرياض اليوم قبلته للرئيس الصيني لهذه
الزياره لعقد هذه القيمه ايضا
اكيد هذه الزياره خادم الحرمين الشريفين
للرئيس الصيني
تلخص ثلاثه قمم مهمه القمه السعوديه
الصينيه بحكم ان العلاقه علاقه قويه
وكبيره بدات في منتصف الثمانينات وتم
التبادل الدبلوماسي بين السعوديه والصين
في التسعينات واستمرت العلاقه تنمو عبر
هذه المرحله من التسعينات الى يومنا هذا
قويه العلاقه بعد عام 2017 بعد زياره خادم
الحرمين وزياره سمو ولي العهد ايضا الى
الصين
وشاهدت نمو الرئيس الصيني الحالي وهو في
فتره الثالثه حديثه منذ توليه السلطه على
تقويه العلاقه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومع الدول الخليفه عاصمه القرار
الان هي الرياض والكل ينظر الى الرياض
بانها هي المنطقه وهي العاصمه التي يتخذ
فيها القرار المهم اقليميا وعربيا وعلى
مستويات اخرى ثانيه بعضها دوليه
ذكرك ايضا للرئيس الصيني اليوم هو في
ولايته الثالثه تم انتخابه همم في
الاسابيع ال- ال- الماضيه وياتي السؤال
هنا هل سيتغير تعاطي التعامل الرئيس
الصيني في علاقته الاقليميه الدوليه في
ولايه الثالثه خصوصا مع منطقه الشرق
الاوسط باي شكل بالعكس واعطى اولويه
واهميه للعلاقه مع المنطقه في الشرق
الاوسط ولذلك راينا انه خلال العام الماضي
كان هنالك زياره للوزراء الخارجيه
الخليجيين وامين العام مجلس التعاون وكان
ايضا هنالك بحث اجتماعات ايضا صينيه
خليجيه في الامم المتحده خلال فتره انعقاد
مؤتمر همم الامم المتحده السنوي في سبتمبر
فهنالك تحضيرات وهنالك استعداده و هنالك
توقع من الجانبين ايضا في تقويه هذه
العلاقه وزيادتنا احنا نعلم انه على مستوى
دول خليجي اليوم هنالك 220 مليار دولار
علاقه تجاريه اقتصاديه في ما بين الصين
والدول مجلس التعاون المملكه الجزء الاكبر
منها والمملكه تمثل اكثر من 17 الى 18% من
استيراد الصين لاحتياجاتها من الطاقه
ولذلك حينما نجد ان 130 مليار من 220 هي
صادرات خليجيه للصين هذا يعطي الاهميه
الاقتصاديه الكبيره ولكنها بقيت معظمها في
اطارها الاقتصادي والتنوع ولذلك تركيز
القمم الثلاثه على التعاون والتنميه
الدكتور التعاون التنميه الاقتصاد هل هي
الملفات التي ستناقش فقط ام ان هناك ابعد
من ذلك في قراءتك لي وفهمك لي ما يحدث من
طبيعه وتغير في العلاقات الدوليه اليوم
وفي النظام العالمي كذلك الصين عضو في
مجلس الامن الدوله دائمه العضويه في مجلس
الامن ولها اهميه في القرارات هي في بعض
الاحيان حاولت ان تاخذ مواقف سياسيه اقرب
الى التوازن حسب الموجه النظر الصينيه قد
لا تروق لنا في بعض الاحيان ولكن اخذت هذه
المواقف سواء في قرارات العلاقه مع ايران
اقصد العلاقه مع ايران المترا واقصد انها
في بعض المواقف مثلا في سوريا اخذت مواقف
مثل مواقف الروسيه على سبيل المثال ففي
بعض المواقف في اليمن مثلا هي ايدت همم
الهدنه ورحبت بالهدنه ولكنها لست يعني لم
تستنكر الحرب بالوكاله التي يقوم بها
الحوثي على المنطقه عندنا فيها فهنالك
قضايا سياسيه انا متاكد راح يكون لها
اهميتها في البحث وانه اي تطور اقتصادي لا
يمكن ان يكون في هذه العلاقه بدون ما يكون
ذلك التطور في البعد السياسي اذا رات
الصين ان الدول العربيه والسعوديه بالذات
حينما تبنت هذه اللقاء هي ايضا الرساله
اخرى احنا استقبلنا الرئيس المملكه رحبت
بالرئيس ترامب في بدايه توليه فتره حكمه
وارحبت بالرئيس وعقد قمم على هذا المستوى
خليجيا وعربيا ولكن ايضا اردنا ان نؤكد
للعالم ان الصيني ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في
العالم واكبر تعداد سكان في العالم يعني
حجمها يستوعب ويستحق ان يكون له هذا
التركيز لها اهميته الكبيره ايضا دكتور
جهه السؤال كذلك كيف يمكن قراءه التحولات
تحولات ما بعد هذا الحدث ما بعدها هذه
القمه باول مره تجتمع الدول العربيه هنا
في الرياض نعم اصيل تبحث الكثير من
الملفات الكثير ايضا من ربما الملفات التي
وصفتها قبل قليل بانها تتعاطى مع الصين
بطريقه لا تروق مثلا لبعض الدول العربيه
وهو ليست على وفاق معها فا الى اي مدى
سيحدث التحول في هذه الملفات سيطره تغير
ايضا على اي اسعد المستقبل بالتاكيد وزراء
الخارجيه هذا ما سوف يكون تركيزهم في
الحوار السياسي مع الجانب الصيني لان
هنالك مجمل القضايا ونحن نريد مواقف اكثر
وضوحا من الجانب الصين دوله عظمى والدوله
كبيره ليست دوله صغيره لا تتوقع منها
قرارات واضحه ولكن نتوقع منها قرارات واضح
بالذات في القضايا العاجله التي تهمنا في
المنطقه في ايضا على سبيل المثال نحن
نحترم العلاقه الاقتصاديه الايرانيه
الصينيه ولا نرى انه هذا من حق كل
الدولتين ان يكون بينهم ولكن التراخي
مواقف السياسيه هذا ما لدي اا يعني ملا
يجب ان يكون من قبل الصين بمعنى اخر نحن
نريد مواقف اكثر وضوحا من الصين اكثر
وضوحا مع المنطقه لان نحن نعاني من
السياسه التدخليه التوسعيه استخدام البعد
الطائفي الصيني الايراني في قضايانا في
المنطقه فنريد ايضا استغلال هذا الجانب من
العلاقه الصينيه الايرانيه القويه لحث
ايران على اخذ سياسه اكثر ما بين هذه
العلاقه الصينيه الايرانيه وتوقيع
اتفاقيات شراكه ربما تابعتها خلال العام
الماضي والعامل الذي سبقوا ايضا كان هناك
تحضير كبير لهذه
العلاقه اليوم همم هناك توجه الى شراك
استراتيجيه مع الصين مع الدول الخليج
تحديدا مع الدول العربيه كذلك الصين كيف
تستطيع ان تخلق توازنا بين هذه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه مع الاعداء في المنطقه
يعني بالتاكيد هي يمكن ان تلعب دور وسيط
ووسيط جيد لسيما انها تستمتع او لها علاقه
قويه مع ايران اقتصاديه ولا علاقه قويه مع
دول الخليج فيمكن ان تلعب دور واحنا
استمعنا ان وزير الخارجيه الصيني كان طرح
مبادره حول الامن في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
ربما يتم التطرق لها خلال هذه السياره
بينه وزراء الخارجيه والبحث في اكثر
تفاصيل طبعا دول الخليج كانت تتطلع
الاتفاقيه التجاره الحره مع الصين ولكنها
لم تنتهي كامل بنودها في لذلك ربما لا
تتوقع في هذه الزياره وانما قد تكون في
المرات القادمه هنالك تطلع ورغبه صينيه ان
يكون هذا الاجتماع بهذه الابعاد الثلاثيه
ان يكون سنوي فساله في المنطقه همم هنا
وسلا يكون في الصين على غرار بعض القيم
التي تنظمها الصين نحن لا نتدخل في شان
الصيني الداخلي على فكره نحن نحترم الخاص
الصينيه نحن مازلنا متمسكين بواحده الصين
مثل همم في الدول العربيه عندها هذا
التمسك في فيما يتعلق مبدا الصين الواحده
نحن لم نتداخل في قضاياهم لا التبت ولا ال
ال ال الايجور ولم نتدخل في الشان الداخلي
الصيني في قضايا ولا في هونغ كونغ ولا في
صراع البلاستيك في في حوله ولا يمكن ان
نكون طرف في اي صراع امريكي صيني في هذا
الجانب لانه لنا علاقتنا المتميزه مع
الجانبين ونحترم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الغرب لاي عين ينظر الى هذه
الزياره باي عين يمكن ان ينظر كذلك الى
مخرجات هذه القمه يعني احنا لنا علاقه
استراتيجيه او علاقه شراكه قويه مع الغرب
فيما يتعلق بالبعد الامني والسياسي ولا
يمكن اغفال هذا الجانب نحن لم نصل مع
الصين الى علاقه استراتيجيه على المستوى
العسكري والدفاع والامني او حتى في بعض
القضايا السياسيه في هذا الجانب ولكنه
يمكن ان تتطور مع التطور العلاقه الذي
يحدث به الجانبه قد يكون هنالك بعض هواجسس
لدى الغرب او الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولكنها تبدد بالمواقف الرسميه التي في
اننا المملكه ودول الخليج والدول العربيه
ان هي ليست بديل الصين ليست بديل للعلاقه
الامريكيه الغربيه بالنسبه لها وانما هي
علاقه لها اهميتها تنمو نموا الاقتصادي
وتوسعنا هو النمو ونحو الشرق وليس نحو
الغرب الغرب جنب يعني انه مو عنده منخفض
ولكن لمن تجد ان النمو في الصين السنوي
يتجاوز 87% فهي الاسواق التي اكثر انفتاحا
بالنسبه لنا الاسواق التي يمكن ان يكون
فيها شراكات مستقبليه فيما بيننا وبينهم
هم طرحوا يعني الحزام والطريق وهم يرون ان
المنطقه العربيه المنطقه مهمه في الوصول
الى اسواقها ومن خلالها ايضا الى الاسواق
الاوروبيه الدكتور برايك بهذه الزياره في
هذه القمه هل توجه الرياض فيها اي رسائل
همم في هذه الزياره وباي باي شكل يعني انا
اعتقادي الرسائل الواضحه ان الرياضيه
عاصمه قرار اقليميه العربيه همم يعني
والحمد لله رب العالمين مكانته دوليه
محفوظه ومعروفه هي ايضا توجه لحلفائها
الغربيين انه لا يمكن فقط يعني ان ان ان
ان ان ان ان
نقبل بكل شروطكم بكل رغباتكم ولكن لنا
علاقتنا اقتصاديه ولنا ااا هذه التوازي
علاقتنا مع كافه الاطراف يجب ان تكون
موجوده نحن نرحب بالانفتاح على العالم
ونرحب بتوسيع همم
مصالحنا الاقتصاديه وننطلق منها هناك
دكتور من يقول بان الصين وفي علاقاتها
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه ايضا ال- ال-
الواسعه هذا النمو الكبير ايضا همم
للصين حتى وبعد جاء احد كورونا عاده مره
اخرى
بشكل اكبر من قبل ولكن هناك من يذهب الى
ان الصين لها اهداف سياسيه دائما
عميقه في كل تعاملاتها الدوليه هل تتفق
ان تفصل المنافع والمصالح الاقتصاديه
والعلاقه الاقتصاديه عن البعد السياسيه
وجدت في افريقيا على فكره وساهمت في
التنميه في مناطق في افريقيا ولكن ايضا
اعتماده في افريقيا على المواد الخام التي
بحاجه لها ومنطقه سوق مهمه ايضا سوف يفرض
اجنده سياسي وهذه الاجنده السياسيه نحن
الان انتقلنا من مرحله القطب الواحد التي
كانت موجوده بالامكان هنالك اربع سنينوهات
مطروحه حقيقه على مستقبل العلاقه الى 2050
استمرار الامريكيه همم قوه اخرى موازيا في
هذا الجانب تفكك المناطق يعني وحوده الى
مرحله العصور الوسطى ونمو جماعه المسلحه
غير الحكوميه كانت هذه ضمن سنه نهايه
المطروحه لعام 2050 ما الذي يمكن يحدث نحن
نرى هنا انه نموه هذه العلاقه التي ترفض
القطب الواحد والتي تريد توازن من مصلحتنا
ان يكون هناك توازن في العلاقه وان لا
يكون لك قطب واحد لانه وجود القطب الواحد
فقط يجعل بقيه الدول تقبل بالاملاءات التي
ما هي مصلحه الخليج الدكتور همم
ان يكون هناك توازن في الاقصاب بين ضرب
بين الشرق ايضا تحدثون عن الولايات
المتحده تحديدا وعن الصين صادراتي 68%
منها الى اسيا واسيا بالنسبه لي هي الشريك
الاساسي المستقبل وهي التي تشهد النمو
اوروبا والولايات المتحده لاصبحت هي مصدره
للطاقه ومصدره الغاز فلذلك انا بالنسبه لي
دخل في مرحله التنافس شبه التنافس الان
فيما يتعلق بمناطق الاسواق لكن ايضا بحكم
العلاقه التاريخيه اللي هي من الاربعين
القرن الماضي هنالك علاقه سياسيه عسكريه
امنيه عقيده قتاليه يعني ارتباطنا اي
ارتباط كبير بمعنى اخر لا نستطيع انفصال
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن مهم
ان يرسل رساله للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انت شريك وشريك مهم جدا ولكن لنا شركاء
اخرين يجب ان نهتم بهم ايضا ان يكون لنا
علاقه معهم متوازنه ومهمه على مستوى
الاقتصاد دكتور على المستوى التبادل همم
التجاري السعوديه والخليج مثلا يصدرون
ثلاثه ملايين برميل يوميا الى الصين
والسؤال هنا ياتي هل فعلا السياسه تتبع
المصالح الاقتصاديه في التعامل مع الصين
يعني الى الان ما زالت علاقه بائع ومشتريه
لكنها لم تنتقل الى مرحله بسبب لانه الصين
ما عنده اطماع توسعيه وعنده اطماع
اقتصاديه هو يطرح خاطئه يعني موضوع الطريق
والحزام ويريد ان يوزع في مصالح
الاقتصاديه ولكنه لا يطرح ايدولوجيات
التصدير ولا يطرح افكار فيما يتعلق بهذا
الجانب هو يحاول ان يركز على هذا البعد
ولذلك التركيز على هذا البعد ايضا يمنح
دول الخليج فرصه جيده سواء في الاستثمار
في الخليج ونحن على فكره اهتمام المملكه
ليس فقط بالبعد الاقتصادي وكذا سمو ولي
العهد الله يحفظه وطرح قضيه اللغه الصينيه
في المدارس وطرح الثقافه الصينيه ايضا يجب
ان تاخذ لانه ما ننسى الصين بلد غني
ثقافيه وغني بشكل كبير جدا ولذلك كل الناس
سعداء انه نسمع بجائزه سمو ولي العهد
الثقافيه في هذا الجانب همم الدكتور
المنتظر تحقيقه من هذه القمه في ظل هذه
المؤشرات همم السياسيه
المضطربه احيانا تقوم تكون ضبابيه او غير
معروفه الملامح مستقبلا كيف يمكن قراءتها
ما المؤشرات التي ستعطيها المنطقه بعد هذه
القمه برايك نحن دائما بحاجه لموقف الصين
في مجلس الامن لانه دوله مهمه جدا ولها
صوت واضح ذلك فهذه بالنسبه لنا يعني لنا
في قضايانا المهمه والتي تطرح على المستوى
الدولي يعني ايضا توسع هذه العلاقه
والمشاركه الصينيه في قضايا التنميه
والبنا التحتيه حينما يكون لدينا خطوط
حديد مربوطه وحينما كل دوله شبكات الطاقه
الكهربائيه وحينما يكون لدينا وسائل
الاتصال متقدمه سوف تساهم في التنميه في
المنطقه والصيني اليوم لديها كافه القدرات
التي يمكن ان تطرحها في هذا الجانب فلذلك
انا ارى انه احد النتائج المهمه هو توسع
خطه التنميه ومشاركه الصين بمشاركه فعليه
فيما يتعلق
بربط هذه المناطق يعني انت تعرف في
افريقيا من
موزمبيق الى
انجولا هنالك خط سكه حديد ربط شرق افريقيا
بغربها وهذا خط مهم جدا الان الصين تطرح
قضيه من النيجر الكاميرون للمحيط او من
النيجر الكاميرون الى الى الى السودان عبر
السودان البحر
اكثر من 20 مشروع في اكثر من 20 دوله
عربيه
هذا المشروع وبالتالي التجاري والطريقه
الاقتصادي الكبير بالتالي الدول العربيه
كيف السعوديه في مقدمتها كيف ستستفيد كيف
ستوام بين خطتها الاقتصاديه وبين ايضا
كذلك هذه الخطه الاقتصاديه التجاريه
الصينيه الواسعه بدات الخطه من 10 سنوات
ولكن
جزء من التنميه اصل المملكه يعني بشكل عمي
رحمه جزء من خطه التنميه الصينيه ولذلك
بنسبه لان رؤيه 20 30 هنالك قواسم مشتركه
في ما بينها الامداد واللوجستك والمدن
الاقتصاديه قضيه مهمه بالنسبه لنا هذه
الخطوط وهذه المناطق هي بحاجه الى الى الى
مستودعات الى مناطق الى موانئ الى خدمات
الى حتى يتم من خلالها نقل البضائع
وبصولها الى الاسواق المستهدفه بطرق افضل
واسرع واقلت كلفه من الطرق التقليديه
وايضا تتجاوز مناطق التوترات يعني في بعض
الاحيان تضطر ان تمر عبر المضائق مائيه
تضطر ان تمر عبر مناطق بحريه فيها قرصنه
الدكتور برايك هل هناك اليوم محددات همم
او مؤشرات مختلفه لفهم هذه العلاقه بين
بكين والخليج اليوم فهم هذه العلاقه كذلك
ما بعد هذه القمه يعني انا العلاقه واضحه
الان وهي في حجمها الاقتصادي الكبير ولكن
مثل ما قلت لك لم يعني لم ننتقل الى البعد
السياسي والدور الصيني فيما يتعلق بسياسه
المنطق على سبيل المثال الصين لها علاقه
جيده وتدعم القضيه الفلسطينيه ولكن ايضا
تت بعلاقه قويه مع اسرائيل فيما يتعلق
بقضايا الدفاع والامن والتصنيع العسكري في
هذا الجانب فهي حاولت ان تكون متوازنه في
علاقته حاولت ان تكون قريبه من كل الاطراف
نحن ما يعنينا طبعا هو طرح قضايانا بشكل
عادل ونرغب ان يكون هنالك النظره صينيه
اكثر عنقا في فهم قضايانا وفي فهم كلا
لانه ما عندنا لا اطماع توسعيه ولا نريد
احتلال دوله اخرى بالقوه ولا نريد ان نفرض
هيمنه في المنطقه كل ما نريد ان يسود
الامن والاستقرار والتنميه في المنطقه
دكتور كيف تقرا هذا التوازن السعودي في
علاقته بالالقاب الدوليه يتحدث عن علاقته
بالولايات المتحده يعني علاقته اليوم
بكينا دعوه الى هذه القمه كذلك الى جمع
العرب على قمه واحده كذلك مع الصين
والخليل كيف انعكس على المصالح السعوديه
برايك دكتور المملكه واضحه في علاقات
المعلومات المتحده الامريكيه البعض حاول
ان يزاود على هذا الجانب ولكن في قناعه
انها علاقه واضحه
اتعب الرؤساء مختلفين ومره عبر مدى زمني
اقرب الى قرن من الزمان في في هذه العلاقه
نحن نعلم ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
شريك اساسي وهى بيننا وبينها مصالح مشتركه
في هذا الجانب لم نساهم على هذه العلاقه
مع الاسف الشديد هنالك بعض مزايدات داخلي
المملكه رفضت ان تستخدم بعض القضايا التي
لنا دور فيها على سبيل المثال اوبي كلاس
رفضت المملكه ان يستخدم قرار اوبك كلاس في
المزادات في الانتخابات المحليه
الامريكيه السنه الداخليه
لامريكان هم يقررون اي الاحزاب يريدون ان
يحكموا ايها الاحزاب يريدون ان ان ان ان
ان يقدم لهم ما يريد ان يقدم لهم فهنا نحن
ننظر لها بالمناظيم مختلفه يهمنا المنطقه
الاسيويه كبيره هنالك جاليه اسلاميه كبيره
في الصين يهم لان يعاملون معامله
المواطنين معامله الحسله مثلهم مثل اي
اخرين ولا نرغب ان يكون ايجابيات اسلاميه
موجوده في اي بلد صيني تستغل هذا البعد
الاجلوجي
في اثاره البلبله والفتنه في اي منطقه همم
نرجع ونقول ايضا انه اقليميه العلاقه مع
ايران بنسبه لها مهمه لانه بالنسبه للصين
ترى انه افغانستان والباكستان وحدوده
وخطوط الانابيب والغاز لها اهميه كبرى
ايران لها 17 دوله حدوديه فهي ترى اهميه
في هذا الجانب لكن لا تستطيع الصين اغفال
دول مستقره في علاقتها معها لم تتحرد
العلاقات الصيفيه الطاقه
ومستقره يعني انا انا يعني اليوم الحمد
لله رب العالمين اصبحت الدول الخليج هي
المزار اذا هو من الاكس بوي اذا هو من
المونديال واذا هي من القمم من الايه يعني
مبتدا الاستثمار اللي صار اصبح الكل تمام
هو اصبحت هي هي هي هي هي
المستهدفه من دون الكبرى التاتي اليها
اشكرك جزيل الشكر لمشاركه في همم هذه همم
وفي هذا الجزء من تغطيه العربيه لقمم
الرئه شكرا لك دكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر
الواحد السيا
همم اذا مشاهدينا لازمنا همم نترقب وصول
الرئيس همم الصيني شيء جنبينج والذي يصل
الى الرياض في زياره رسميه بدعوه من العهد
السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز سيعقد
فيها كما ذكرنا قمم ثلاث سعوديه صينيه
خليجيه صينيه وعربيه ايضا صينيه استنتابع
معكم ايضا في نشراتنا القادمه همم هذه
التغطيه من هنا من السيتيو العربيه في
المركز الاعلامي المصاحب لهذه
القمم انتهت همم نافذتنا من هنا عود مره
اخرى الى زميل خالد الاستعمال نشره
الرابعه خالد اليك
شكرا نايف
حضرتك
من مجلس التعاون الخليجيه لاجتماع
التحضيري للمجلس الاعلى لمجلس التعاون
الذي سيعقد الجمعه
وزير الخارجيه العماني بدر البوسعيدي
والذي تراس بلاده المجلس للسنه الجديده
الاجتماع قبل يومين من انعقاد القمه
الخليجيه الصينيه في الرياض التي تعد
الاولى من نوعها على مستوى العلاقات
الخليجيه الصينيه
مقر الاجتماع من الرياض مع مراسل العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربيه اهلا عبد المحسن كيف
يتم التحضير
لهذه القمه
الخليجيه الصينيه من قبل الوزاره الخارجيه
نعم خالد بالفعل تم اليوم عقد تحضيري
استماع تحضيري للوزراء خارجيه دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي برئاسه وزير الخارجيه
العماني الذي تحدث في هذا همم في هذا
الاجتماع مع وزراء خارجيه مجلس التعاون
الخليجي الذي حضروا بشكل كامل مع دام وزير
الخارجيه الاماراتي الذي حضرها همم مندوب
او بالنيابه عن في هذا الاجتماع الاجتماع
كان تحضيري للتنسيق لاجتماعيا مهمين
ينتظرون الخليج تحديدا الاجتماع الخليجي
الخليجي الثالث والاربعين للمجلس الاعلى
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي سيكون يوم
الجمعه بعده همم توالي ان سيكون الاجتماع
الخليجي الصيني وهو الاول من نوعه على
مستوى العلاقات الخليجيه الصينيه سيكون
هناك حديث همم بين همم الصين ودول الخليج
بشكل مباشر عن ابرز الفرص والتحديات وايضا
ال- همم الفرص التي قد يجدها كلها طرفين
في هذه الطاوله سينما بان الصين تستورد ما
يقارب 72% من احتياجاتها النفطيه في
المنطقه هنالك مشتركات كبيره جدا بين دول
الخليج واصيل وايضا فرص ومصالح مشتركه
الصين تريد همم ان تضمن همم امدادات انه
الغاز من دول الخليج وايضا الخليج يريد
همم من خلال هذه القمه بان يعذب شركته
الاقتصاديه مع الصين من خلال الاتفاقيات
المشتركه ومن خلال الاتفاقيات التي قد
تعقد بينها الطرفين الاصليه ما بين الرؤى
الخليجيه المحليه تتحدث عن الرؤى
الاقتصاديه وربطها ومؤمتها مع همم
الصين الطريق
والمبادره الحزام والطريق همم لاحياء
الطريق الحرير بشكل عام خالد اضعك في
الاجواء حيث العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
تستعد لهذه القمم بشكل
كبير الاعلام ال- اا خليجيه والعربيه
والصين وايضا الاربعه الدول المشاركه
الاخرى من خارج هذه المنظومه نتحدث عن
كمبوديا وباكستان واندونيسيا ومن افريقيا
تشارك السنغال في هذه القمه حتى الان تم
تاكيد حضور
ووصول ربما خلال ساعات القادمه ويوم غدا
اكثر من 30 قائد امير ورئيس وملك وممثل
لهذه الدول التي ستحضر هذه الاجتماعات همم
التي ستعقد يوم الجمعه همم اليوم وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه اصطبقت هذه الاجتماعات
في الحديث بشكل همم كامل عن هذه
الاجتماعات وهمم عبر بيان قالت فيه عن
القمه الخليجيه الصينيه
بعيده المدى للعلاقات بين الصين ودول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي ايضا تحدثت الخارجيه
الصينيه عن
الزياره الرئيس الصيني الى السعوديه وقالت
بانها ستسمح بالارتقاء بالشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله
وجديد بين السعوديه والصين ايضا على مستوى
على مستوى القمه العربيه قالت وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه بان هذه القمه العربيه
الصينيه ستكون فارقه ونقطه فارقه في تاريخ
العلاقات العربيه الصينيه بعد قليل او
ربما خلال الساعات القادمه سيصل للرئيس
الصيني سيتم استقبال واستقبال رسميا
غدا ستعقد جلسات المباحثات السعوديه
سيكون يوم سعودي صيني خالص يتم من خلال
العقد اتفاقيات في مجالات مختلفه وتوقيع
وثيقه الشراكه همم الصينيه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بين الصين والسعوديه وهي ما
يتم الاعلان سيتم الاعلان عن تفاصيل يوم
الغد خالد شكرا لك عبد المحسن الحربي
مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
رابعه بعد قليل
الالم ماراثون في مارب يضم اكثر من 2009
اهلا بكم
صدور ارقام ميزانيه العام الجديد 2023
والارقام الفعليه للعام الحالي وكما في كل
عام ستكون هناك تغطيه خاصه لهذه الارقام
المستجدات الماليه والاقتصاديه والتوقعات
ايضا المستقبليه لاداء اقتصاد المملكه من
المتوقع ان تظهر الارقام او تظهره تسجيل
اول في الميزانيه منذ 2013 بدعم من ارتفاع
اسعار النفط في العام الحالي اما الميزان
الجديد التي ستعلن عنها السعوديه هي
الاخرى تتوقع فائضا في الميزانيه لعام
2023 بحسب وزاره الماليه فان ميزانيه
العمل 2023 الى تقويه المركز الماليه
الحكومه من خلال الحفاظ على مستويات امنه
من الاحتياطيات الحكوميه لتعزيز قدرات
المملكه على التعامل مع الصدمات الخارجيه
وتستهدف سياسه الماليه تعزيز الاحتياطيات
الحكوميه لدى البنك المركزي السعودي بجزء
من الفوائد المتوقع تحقيقها
من موقع انعقاد المؤتمر الصحفي للميزانيه
السعوديه تنضم الينا مفرده العربيه نادين
هاني نادين مرحبا بك نادين الاستعدادات
للاعلان في المؤتمر الصحفي عن ارقام وبنود
هذه الميزانيه كيف ترصدها لنا وما ابرز
ماده تضمنته يعني في هذا العام
السعوديه
زياره تاريخيه الى السعوديه ولكن ايضا
اليوم الاعلان عن الميزانيه العامه للدوله
اهميه الميزانيه هي انه تعطينا ملامح
العام القادم نحن نعلم انه المملكه تعيش
ورشه اقتصاديه لتنويع اقتصادها خارج النفط
وهي مدفوعه بالدرجه الرئيسيه بالانفاق
المحلي الذي يقوم به صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه والسياسات التي تضعها الحكومه
لتنويع الاقتصاد
اليوم مساء اليوم سيصدر بيان الميزانيه
مؤتمر صحفي لوزير الماليه محمد الجدعاني
عاده كان من المفترض انه باليوم التالي
بيكون في مؤتمر الميزانيه بتمصيل كل وزاره
كيف سيكون جزئها من هذه الميزانيه هذا لن
يحصل هذا العام في تاجيل لمؤتمر الميزانيه
بسبب القمم الصينيه التي ستحصل في الرياض
اليوم نتراقب اولا الاعلان عن الارقام
الفعليه ل 22 ماذا يعني ذلك نحن بمطلع
السنه بنفس الشهر من العام الماضي تم وضع
ارقام ميزانيه 2022 اليوم بيصيرفي جرده مع
نهايه السنه ما الذي انفق فعليا ما الذي
حققته فعليا المملكه من ايرادات ومن
الفائز الفائض اللي كان تم تعديله يعني
بنهايه الربع الثالث المملكه مؤخرا نعتمدت
السياسه انه بكل ربع بتعطينا ابديت بتحدث
هذه الارقام بنهايه الربع الثالث حدثوا
ارقام الميزانيه يتوقعون انه ننهي 2022 مع
فاء 90 مليار ما اسمعوا انه ممكن ان يكون
الفوائد شوي اعلى من ذلك لانه خالد اسعار
النفط هذا العام وصلت 128 دولار على برنت
والانتاج المملكه كان جيد كان فقط تخفيضات
الانتاج دخلت حيز التنفيذ من نوفمبر
فبالتالي هذه الفوائد اهميتها انه كما
ذكرت قبل قليل اين ستذهب جزء منها بيذهب
لتدعيم احتياطي العام للدوله هي اللي هو
احتياطي النقد الاجنبي لدى سامه جزء يذهب
لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه وصندوق التنميه
الوطنيه اللي هي عم تنفق على المشاريع
العملاقه داخل المملكه جزء يذهب لا ادينا
العام لانه نحن نعلم بمرحله معينه سابقا
عندما كان في عجز بالميزانيه الدوله الطرق
المملكه للاستدانه بالتالي في الان توجه
لاطفاء جزء من الدين وجزء اخر يوجه
لمشاريع استراتيجيه همم لم يتم الاعلان
عنها نحاول ان نفع من وزير الماليه ماذا
يعني المشاريع الاستراتيجيه ايضا اليوم
بتم اعلان ميزانيه 2003 و20 ماذا نتراقب
العام القادم عاده المملكه متحفظه بحسبه
سعر النفط نحن لا نعرف لا نعلم على اي سعر
نفط بيوضع والميزانيه هو قائد العام
القادم اقل بكثير من هذه السنه عام الحكم
شوي فوق 9 مليار ريال فاذن هذه الارقام
اللي راح نتقبه كما الارادات المتوقعه
العام القادم كم الانفاق وعلى ماذا سيواجه
بالدرجه الاولى
معك كل الاجاباتها من خلال مؤتمر الصحفي
للميزانيه في نشرته شكرا جزيلا لك نادين
هاني من مقر انقاد المؤتمر الصحفي
للميزانيه السعوديه
بهدف تشجيع الاشخاص دول اعاقه وادماجهم في
المجتمع والتزامن مع يومهم العالمي نظمه
الجمعيه الدوليه لرعايه ضحايا الحروب
والكوارث مبادره قادرون التي يتنافس فيها
اكثر من 200 شخص في منافسات الرياضيه
المختلفه المبادره التي حملت شعار لاعاقه
مع الاراده نظمت بدعم السلطه المحليه في
المغرب ومركز الملك سلمان للغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه
بعكاز الامل لا بعكاز الالم يقف ذو الهمم
من الجرحى والمبتورين شامخين متحدين
الاعاقه في ماراثون هو الاول في مارب ثم
اكثر من 200 متسابقين اختلفت اعاقاتهم
وتشابهت احلامهم وطموحاتهم في التمسك
بالحياه والركض نحو خط النهايه والله
الفعاليات هذه اخرجه نحن من عالم الاعاقه
الى عالم همم ان احنا قادرون على المشاركه
والمسابقه
واهتمام
الحكومه بهذا الشيء هما مهما كانت اعاقتنا
مهما كنا غير قادرين الا ان احنا قادرين
فنمارس التحديات نحتفل باليوم المعاقين
وانا من نفس المعاقين ونشكره دائما ونحن
فرحين باليوم العالمي للمعاقين
ونحن سعداء بمشاركه الجميع من المجتمع
ونشكر الملك سلمان ومركز الملك سلمان
الدائمين لهذا اليوم
ليس يوما واحدا بالاسبوع للاشخاص ذوي
الاعاقه حظي بها جرح الحرب واصحابه الهمم
في مارب بدعم من السلطه المحليه ومركز
الملك سلمان
لمشروع مركز الاطراف
انشطه امتدت بعد الماراثون لتشمل لعبه
الشطرنج ومواهب الرسمي ثم مباريات كره
القدم في مشهد رسم الفرحه على فئه عانه
تجاهل والحرمان
يهدف هذا النشاط الى ادماج همم ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه وذوي الهمم في المجتمع
همم بحقهم في ممارسه نشاطات او ممارسه كره
القدم او ممارسه اي رياضات يخلق همم وهذا
الانشطه التخلق لديهم حافز كبير في دمجهم
في المجتمع
الاراده هو شعار مبادره قادرون التي هدفت
الى تشجيعه وادماجه شريحه ذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه
وفعاليات الرياضيه
الشريفه يثبتها هؤلاء ان الاعاقه اعاقه
الفكر لائقه البدن محمود الحميدي لقناه
العربيه مارب
عه بعد قليل
تزامنا مع مونديال قطر القهوه السعوديه
والاكلات الشعبيه تتصدر فعاليات سوق
القيصري
رئيس الصينيه
للسعوديه تستمر ثلاثه ايام تتخللها قيمتان
خليجيه عربيه
وزراه خارجات الدول الخليج يعقدون اجتماع
تحضيريا للقمه الخليجيه الصينيه
لفائضا المتوقعه 9 مليارات ريال مجلس
الوزراء السعوديه عقد جلسه لاقرار ميزانيه
العامل الجديد
بعد تقطيع اسبانيا احتفالات عربيه مغربيه
بتاهل اسود الاطلس الى ربع النهائي
اهلا بكم العديد من الانشطه والفعاليات
تشهدها محافظه الاحساء تزامنا مع بطوله
كاس العالم قطر 2022 سوق القيصريه تاريخي
احد المواقع التي اختارتها هيئه التراث
لاقامه فعاليات متنوعه استقطبت حتى الان
اكثر من 75,000 زائر من مختلف الجنسيات
عالي اللغبي
[موسيقى]
وسط الهفوف في التاريخ يشهد سوق القيصريه
حراقه سياحيا وثقافيا كاحد ابرز المزارات
السياحيه لجماهير مونديال قطر 20 22
فعاليات المتنوعه ضمن مهرجان واحه الاحساء
سجلت حضوره من اها للاحساء والزوارها من
مختلف الجنسيات من ابرزها دول الخليج
العربي
هو سابقا ما كان موجود
في قطر وهي ايضا لمناطق اخرى في المنطقه
الشرقيه هي بالفعل ما كان جميل اذا كنت
تبحث عن الموقع الممتاز
من السوق القيصريه وما شاء الله يعني شفت
المكان الج
والجلسات الجميله ومهرجان صراحه يعني
يشكرون عليه اهل الحسر دايما اهل الحسن ما
شاء الله يعني سباقين في الاشياء الجميله
تتصدر والقهوه السعوديه والماكولات
الحساويه الشعبيه فعاليه السوق القيصريه
كما تضيف الجلسات الخارجيه تجربه ثريه
للاسر والزوار للاستمتاع باجواء وسط
الهفوف العتيقه عليها رقم واحد
اليوم
مناظر جميله
ومنطقه
اثريه ومنطقه تحب الزوار وتحب اللي
يعشقونها
اكثر من 75 الف زائر ضمن فعاليات السوق
القيصريه احدى مستهدفات هيئه التراث
الراميه لتنشيط المواقع التراثيه في
محافظه الاحساء تزامنا مع بطوله كاس
العالم المقاومه حاليا في قطر
العربي العربي
الاطباق العالميه وتجربه التسوق الفريده
شاهد المتروك
من موسم الرياض نتواجد فيها وهي منطقه
المربع التي تتميز بوجود خمس مطاعم عالميه
منها اليابانيه والايطاليه والامريكيه الى
جانب في حي ان يعتبر نوعا ما تراثيا لوجود
قصر الملك عبد العزيز والمتحف الوطني
[موسيقى]
منطقه المربع التي تتميز بجمالها خلال
الفتره المسائيه لم تخلو من الانشطه
المميزه حيث يتمكن الاشخاص من توثيق قسمهم
بالورده اليابانيه وتصويرها على الارض
[موسيقى]
يتمكن زوار منطقه المربع من استخدام مرافق
المربع وايضا التجول في المنطقه التي تبلغ
اكثر من 260 الف متر مربع وايضا الاستمتاع
بتجربه التسوق السريعه لكن الفاخره ايضا
من الرياض شهد المتروك العربي العربيه
مع دخول الفصل الشتاء وبدايه موسم
المربعانيه تهب بعض الرياح القادمه من
المرتفع السيبيري تسمى بالرياح الشماليه
تفاصيل مع خالد الزعل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حركه الهواء من مكان الى مكان اخر تسمى
بالرياح فهي تنتقل من مكان الضغط العالي
الى مكان الضغط
المنخفض وكل ما زاد الفارق بينهما زادت
حده عصف الريح والمنخفضات والمرتفعات
محليه
وعالميه فمع دخول موسم الصيف الفعلي يبدا
يؤثر علينا منخفض الهند برياح السموم ومع
دخول موسم الشتاء الفعلي يبدا يؤثر علينا
المرتفع السيبيري بالرياح الشماليه
البارده خلال الموسم المربعانيه والشبط
والعقارب تهب كل رياح الارض عاصفه والنخل
لا تنحني الا ذوائبه ان كبيره كبيره
مصائبه
فتغير الاحوال الجويه عن السائد هذا مؤشر
على تدخل مناخي مغايرا عن السائد فسائد في
الشتاء البروده احيانا تنكمش البروده
ويعود الدفء وهذا مؤشر على قرب سحب ماطره
واحيانا تنقشع هذه السحب ويزرقها وجه
السماء وهذا مؤشر على قرب رياح بارده
والعامه يقولون البرد وجهه وجذيب ما تدري
معين يجيك
[موسيقى]
الختام وبالعناوي
رئيس الصينيه الى الرياض في زياره الرسميه
العربيه
تراه خارجيه الدول الخليج ياخذون اجتماع
ان تحضيريا للقمه الخليجيه
كفايه ايضا متوقعه 9 مليارات ريال مجلس
الوزراء السعوديه عقدوا جلسه لاقرار
ميزانيه العام الجديد
بعد تخاطيه اسبانيا احتفالاتن عربيه
ومغربيه بتاهل اسود الاطلس الى ربع نهائي
[موسيقى]